- Who do I think I'm gonna get?
Dumbo.
Not a princess?
I think Dumbo could be a princess.
(whimsical music)
- This Buzzfeed quiz is gonna
tell me which Disney princess
I am.
- You say it's as simple as
that, but you don't know me.
(chuckles)
It's never that simple.
- Well I hope I get Belle,
cuz I think she's pretty cool.
- What are my choices here?
I'm thinking Rapunzel maybe.
- I would like to be Nala.
Let's see what happens.
- Would you rather have the
most beautiful singing voice
but you can't make money off of it,
be a famous pop star
but everyone hates you.
I'll go with the first one.
- Well I guess the second
one is more like my character
Gaston and I'm sort of in
his head space right now,
so I'm gonna be a famous pop
star but everybody hates you.
- Would you rather spend
20 years in jails but
be rich and famous--
- Or never be rich or famous
but have your freedom?
Obviously.
- I'll take my freedom, Buzzfeed.
- I'm gonna think as Luke
in this answer and say
I'd rather be never rich or
famous but have my freedom.
- Would you rather be the
best athlete in the world
or be the smartest person in the world?
Hm.
- I'll let my body speak
for itself on this one.
- Oh, I can't skip because I can't choose.
- Smart.
- If you're smart, you're
smart, if you're an athlete,
your body is gonna deteriorate.
- Any animal you want
as a domesticated pet.
Any kind of car and, no, pet.
Of course.
I want a cheetah.
- I've always wanted like
a little capuchin monkey.
- Animal, I'd have an elephant as a pet.
- I don't know, cuz not
all animals are meant to be
domesticated, that's kind of not fair.
Although I can tell
that the car and clothes
is the superficial answer, right.
I'm gonna go for any animal you want,
cuz then you can always set it free.
- Live in an incredible mansion,
but have to stay home always.
That sounds rubbish.
- Travel anywhere in the world
but live in a tiny apartment,
that's basically my life.
- I love luxury and living in luxury,
but I think I love
travel a little bit more.
So I'll take the apartment
and I'll hear my wife
complain about it later.
- Kick anyone's ass with
awesome superpowers.
Heal any illness or injury,
saving any life you want to.
Obviously that one.
- I'm gonna take they
pacifist approach here,
if only because I'm
promoting a Disney film.
- These are hard.
- Would you rather know
the answer to any question
on any test or always
have the perfect comeback
to use on your enemies?
- I'm already pretty good with comebacks,
so I'm gonna go with know
the answer to any question
on any test.
- Ooh.
Let's go perfect comeback.
- Yes, that's terrible, but yes.
- I don't like having enemies.
I would rather have the
answer to any question.
(laughs heartily)
- Ladies and gentlemen, look at this.
We call that serendipitous.
- I'm Belle!
I'm Belle, I'm Belle.
- I got Ariel.
Is that good?
- This is interesting.
Elsa.
- I got Jasmine.
Everybody knows you for
your beauty, but you're
more than just a pretty face.
You have an adventurous
spirit and a strong will too.
- Do I agree with it?
I have to, right, isn't
that the law of Buzzfeed.
- I feel pretty chuffed.
A Whole New World is one of
my favorite Disney songs.
- She's a red head.
I love red heads.
- Thank you, Buzzfeed, for
bringing out my inner Belle.
- I think Josh Gad who's the voice of Olaf
would be very happy that I got Elsa.
♫ Let it go, let it go
♫ Let it go, let it go, let it go